welcome to team bridge leisure and
cultural services
leisure and resorts manage four leisure
centres three outdoor seasonal swimming
pools and an 18 hole pitch and pot golf
course
green space is an active leisure
management maintain 35 parks and open
spaces including formal parks such as
courtney park and the den and are more
natural open spaces such as dawlish
warren national nature reserve and decoy
country park
we managed 22 playing pitchers and 30
play areas skate parks tennis courts and
bowling greens within the district's
parks and open spaces
the team put together an annual
programme of events including guided
walks and volunteer work days as well as
managing a grounds maintenance contract
to keep all the open spaces usable and
attractive
green spaces active leisure team run the
dance this way walk this way and devon
active villages project which are
externally funded and work with
residents as an alternative way to get
physically active as well as supporting
clubs and devon wide sports development
initiatives
our resorts team look after our beaches
and resort areas working with the rnli
to provide our beach lifeguarding
service the team manage and administer
beach huts and chalets in addition to
providing winter storage and dingy
wracking facilities for boat owners at
polysteps car park in timmouth
linking the resorts of tim muffensholden
is the passenger ferry managed by us
working with a local operator and here's
uncle taco
there's tons on
what where's it all on
can't you see
it says it's on a dawlish dawlish warren
team bridge newton abbott it's all over
team bridge